this is a production of Cornell
University
alright good afternoon thank you to be
opportunity to talk about the research
I've been doing and we shall see what
his lot over the last year today we're
using mass spectrometry to study citrus
greening disease and there's a number of
contexts underway on citrus greening the
sea lab right now but this figure here
represents the central objective of the
project that I'm going to talk about
today where we're trying to appear
inside the psyllid and understand the
proteins and protein interactions that
are essential for transmission of the
citrus greening pathogen the bureau
after five years of facility insect
vector of the disease sorry yes I
collector without I just told you to
keep these terms straight hope you keep
not if I have a plant biologist by
training this is the outline if I talk
first I'm going to go to a tea
production to the citrus greening half
the system then I'm going to discuss the
work that we're doing with quantitative
proteomics to understand the proteins
involved and the proteins affected by by
the psyllid harboring the citrus
greening pathogen the third part of my
talk I'm going to review your post that
we're taking to discover protein
interactions within the insect vector
that may be critical for transmission
so I'm going to introduce the path of
system first of all I just have to say I
was just delighted to meet professor
Lorbeer here before the talk and I
understand that he is they then he is a
California citrus farmer who was
actually helping fund this work and so
you know that he certainly more than any
of us knows the threat to this disease
to the citrus industry were certainly
highly motivated to address this problem
because of the clear and present danger
that it poses to the citizens in this
country so I just to just to back up a
little bit citrus greening disease he's
also known as long long game or hlb kuan
lun bing means yellow shoot disease and
this figure down here on the Left shows
the yellow foliage that's characteristic
of trees that are affected with the
packaging the pathogen that the first of
all the disease was first detected in
Florida in 2005 it's now a widespread
throughout Florida and it just appeared
in California in 2012 there's a lot that
we don't know about this disease but it
has been associated with the bacterial
pathogen candidatas libre dr. asiaticus
i say associated because Koch's
postulates have not been strictly
fulfilled given that we cannot culture
this bacteria
to a healthy plant to make it stick the
the consequences of the disease is a
reduction in the quality and quantity of
fruit you see here on the lower right
these immature fruit that don't properly
ripen there the diseased trees are
highly susceptible to fruit draw and the
reality for farmers is that they see a
reduction in the quantity and quality of
their crops for several years before the
trees died the Asian citrus psyllid
pictured right here is a hemiptera
insect piercing sucking insect which
beats on plant floats out this is in the
same group of insects such as the aphids
and white flies that are well
characterized for their ability to
transmit plant disease so to get this
work off the ground we put a bunch of
effort in the last year and a half to
establish the crew screening research
infrastructure of cornell and i'm just
going to review some of the some of the
work that we've done in that regard I
also do want to acknowledge the funding
that we've gotten from the California
citrus research board and from the USDA
to set up this research there's been an
increasing awareness over the last few
years of the need to bring in the best
possible science to help establish or
discover cures or treatments to this
disease and we're fortunate and grateful
for that funding so the main center of
operations for our citrus and silver
earring research is in the biology
dermatology lab up at the top of tower
road and so here we've got some reaching
growth chambers where we grow citrus
seedlings we've also got greenhouses
where we can grow mature citrus trees
and then they've got rear in facilities
for establishing and maintaining
colonies of the Asian citrus psyllid
vector and so this is a picture of the
containment that we use
within these growth chambers use pub
dorms and we've got separate growth
chambers for for insects that are
healthy that have never been exposed to
the pathogen and feed on healthy trees
and another growth chamber where we rear
silicon defective trees and and we
monitor the infection status of the
insects by by qpcr to make sure that
everything goes according to plan there
are a lot of collaborations that
Michelle has developed that has enabled
us to do the research that we do so I
mentioned the facilities that we've set
up in Ithaca I'll just talk about the
support that we've gotten around the
country at usda-ars in beltsville john
heart tones lab has given us advice and
support on how to grow citrus in the
northeast USDA for Pierce is home to
some of our our core collaborators we've
received training and protocols on the
sill apology maintenance citrus grafting
we've received a lot of plant and insect
material from them as well UC Davis I'm
really not going to talk too much today
about the work that is ongoing at UC
Davis but we're part of a
multidisciplinary team trying to develop
early detection technologies mrs. green
and a UC Davis they have a biosafety
level three contained research facility
where they can keep these infected
plants and psyllids very nearby the
citrus growing regions that's one of the
benefits that we have a typical if the
soul its escape
but still we keep under lock and key UC
Riverside they have a citrus germ plasm
repository to get seeds from and
hacienda heights I'll talk about this
more in it but this is the site in
California where the first inspected
tree was discovered it and we've
received material from trees in that
vicinity as part of an effort to track
the spread of the disease from that
first infection so Florida and
California these are the two largest
sutras producing states in the country
although Texas produces a decent amount
of citrus as well there's some in
Arizona and I'm just going to review the
differences in the situation with the
disease in Florida California and also
some of the differences in the industry
in those states so Florida the psyllid
vector was first found in 1998 and the
first disease tree was discovered in
2005 since that time the disease has
spread all threats it's essentially
endemic there are no regions of the
state where the cyllage and where the
disease do not exist this has caused
significant economic loss greater than 5
billion dollars eight thousand plus jobs
have fallen by the wayside as they're
these citrus growers have really
suffered a severe blow to their
livelihood the Florida oranges are
primarily sold for juice so you know one
of the problems that they have is just a
major overcapacity with these juice
production facility it's a bait they
can't keep running but they're trying to
salvage their crop so I guess I'll just
stop and say that the diseased fruit
while it is of lower quality they have
found that it can be blended
other fruits to salvage their profit as
what they're currently doing you see
that in the supermarket with mango
orange juice know it blends that are
currently being made available that's
largely in response to this California
is a completely different situation the
psyllid was first detected in California
in 2008 although by this time the
psyllid has spread over a fairly wide
range in Southern California there has
only been one tree that's been confirmed
inspected by a cute pcr assay for direct
detection of the liberal vector pathogen
that tree was discovered in 2012 and
there have been no sorts of diseased
trees since that that there can be an
extended incubation period a systematic
trees that don't test positive so people
are kind of walking on eggshells there a
California there's less juice production
more the fruit is sold as fresh market
for fresh market consumption and that
gives growers fewer options for
salvaging it is news crop so these
organizations the California research
and development foundation or sorry
florida citrus research and development
foundation the California citrus
research board these are these are
agencies that are run by citrus growers
how to save their livelihood and so
we're funded by them and we're working
hard to give them practical solutions
that they can apply so this figure it
just captures the critical biological
players in this interaction that we're
going to discuss in a bit more detail
over the course of the top so see laughs
chain of Edison bureau bacterial Atticus
is the grim negative
pathogen associated with the disease as
I said diaphoretic deference to tree is
the vector citrus is the plant that were
interested in the other two elements on
this slide first let's just talk about
the bacterial symbiosis of the Asian
citrus psyllid and this is one of the
characteristics of different insects is
they're known to have highly evolved
ancient relationship for bacterial
endosymbiosis some cases these bacteria
some ions serve to provide a nutritional
supplementation for the nutritionally
unbalanced diet of plant phloem sat in
the psyllid there there could be a more
complex relationship with this
environment so I'll going through a
little bit later and another element
which is relevant to this path of system
is the fact that there is a
bacteriophage which infects with Roger
and this does not appear to enter a
lytic cycle either in citrus or in the
phage but certainly in the field of
people doing research on this that the
idea of inducing a lytic cycle in the
phage to kill the bacteria is one of the
control strategies that's being
considered I just wanted to focus a
little bit on the pathogen itself these
are flown limited fastidious bacteria
and this is a cross section of set bail
on it sells and so these m's are
mitochondria and these arrows point to
the bacterial cells this is a more
close-up version of the other selves
right there the genome size is around
1.2 megabases this is a reduced genome
sooner with syringes around six mega
bases and it's an info cellular
bacterium it never needs to penetrate
the cell from the outside because it's
in
directly into the cell by the siletz and
in keeping with that genome analysis
shows that this pathogen is lacking the
classical type 3 secretion system genes
and genes including extracellular to
creative enzymes we know a bit about how
the probe actor moves within the acp not
as much as we know about how viruses
move within Athens so that's what this
picture is on the right this is from
Stewart creation circular transmission
of plant lattices and so I just want to
focus on on at least in the in the a
precision what we know about the
barriers to transmission in this circuit
of transmission pathway so this is the
plant flown the pathogen is taken up in
the stylet from the plant flown it
travels into the gut and here is the
first barrier to transmission that we
typically consider which is the escape
from the gut crossing this membrane into
the kemah sealed or open circulatory
system of the insect and in the heel
there's importance of the cellular
immune system which must be evaded for
the pathogen to successfully travel to
the surface of the salivary gland the
pathogen needs to enter the salivary
glands so it can be injected opponent of
saliva into a healthy plant completing
the transmission cycles the objective of
this work why we want to understand the
transmission within the cylinder is to
identify novel targets in the vector of
Loxy last transmission so
I think an obvious question after that
is okay well you have those targets well
then what do you do and so I just want
to take the opportunity in this slide to
discuss some of the technology
development that has been done that's
currently still underway to develop
mechanisms for for transfer of this
technology into application in the field
so there have been proof of concept
established for two related gene
silencing methods and the first is in
RNA interference rnai based approach
using a ctd vector the citrus tristeza
virus and the this is a transient
expression system as a non-transgenic
approach ctv is flown restricted so any
kind of silencing would occur in in the
phloem which is the ground zero for
interaction between the the insect of
the plant and the pathogen this has been
shown to be used to silence plant genes
in the phloem and also the silence
insect genes when the insect takes up
the CTD vector during field this
technology is being developed primarily
by dr. Len Dawson also in dr. Gowda at
University of Florida lake alfred and
these these are among our collaborators
in Florida that are excited to work with
us we have good targets for silencing
the other approach is related to this
but this is this is more of an in vitro
synthesis of double-stranded RNA
specifically directed at target genes
which are desired to be silenced this is
primarily applied with a root French
delivery system dr. Wayne hunter and
shabab shatters are the drivers behind
this technology obviously you know
there's a lot of technical hurdles to
produce sufficient amounts of
double-stranded RNA to French a lot of
groups but but they're they're moving
this technology along if there's there's
reason to think that these have these
have potential for for helping growers
in the field so some of the work that
I'm going to talk about now is is
showing how we're using proteomic
analysis of the Asian citrus psyllid
vector to discover new targets for
silencing ideal targets in this case
would be psyllid specific single coffee
genes but furthermore in the second part
of the research component of the talk
i'm going to talk about the protein
interaction analysis that we're doing
and this is meant to identify protein
interactions critical for transmission
our technology gives us tools to
understand the topological shape of
these protein interactions which will
really give us a more direct route to
design specifically tailored inhibitor
to disrupt penetrata both of these both
of these objectives the Seelie Olaf has
unique capabilities to to address them
and I will move into the research
component of the talk now so really the
the question that we're first trying to
answer here is what happens to the
vector while they Harbor the pathogen
that they're transmitting we consider
this important because if we can
understand the molecular levels details
of this of this the transmission within
the insect we can potentially discover
an Achilles heel that we could target
for suppression of transmission and I'm
just going to take a couple minutes now
to just give you just the very basic
overview of mass spectrometry proteomics
just to explain why we consider
proteomics to be a valuable approach
here proteins are critical molecules to
all life forms on Earth they're involved
in there are structural functionaries hi
lytic functions and there's been an
explosion of new hardware and software
tools to use proteomics to study all the
proteins in the sampler these all the
proteins that can be extracted from your
biological sample and the mass
spectrometry basically gives us a tool
to identify proteins by breaking the
proteins down into peptides which have
unique signatures or masses which can be
detected with the mass spectrometry this
is just a simple schematic of the mass
spectrometer but really the the main
take home from this is that there's
several questions that we can answer
using mass spectrometry and the first
one is what are the proteins in my
sample next we can ask how abundant are
these proteins are there differences in
the levels of proteins in simple a and
sample B we have the tools to learn
about post translational modifications
of protein and as you'll see later in
the talk there are strategies to use
mass spectrometry from the omics to
understand what proteins are interacting
in a given system ok so the conditions
were fairly simple for this first
experiment I told you that we have these
separate colonies of healthy insects and
insects that are harboring the citrus
greening pathogen and so we did three
bio reps of 100 healthy insects and a
hundred infected insects this was the
whole insect samples and I'm going to go
into this in a little bit more detail
later but we use a purple gradient
method to generate a microbe enriched
fraction from a homogenate of infected
insects and and we use that micro and so
this this has microbial cell but also
the insect cells associated
with the micro that we establish all
this with QVC our analysis of these
samples so so these are the two
different sample types that we that we
start with the next step is extract the
proteins from the samples to digest the
proteins into peptides using Krypton
mass spectrometer is used to sequence
the peptides and then their bio
informatics software pipelines that are
used to match the peptides to the parrot
protein that they're derived from we did
this work with collaborators at
university washington and the bottom
line data is that from all this analysis
we identified almost 750,000 peptides
which we mapped to almost 3850 unique
proteins and essentially the the main
method that we use to quantify the
abundance of these proteins with
spectral counting of the peptides that
correspond to each protein how many
peptides came from a given protein in
sample a versus sample b gives us a
proxima Schnoor estimation of the
abundance of this protein in the
original sample so i'm going to go
through some of the results from this
study and i guess the first set of
results I want to just kind of introduce
you to by posing one of the questions
that we asked a lot we know that see
lass is a plant mountain but it's less
clear whether it is also a pathogen of
the insect and victory and insects
psyllids white flies and eight kids they
have an unusual new repertoire they lack
the classical I am game pathway genes
these are possibly involved in
gram-negative bacterial response there's
speculation that one of the reasons for
this is that it's important for the
insect
a permissive immune system if you will
that will help cultivate relationships
with endo-san miles so we we use this we
might approach data to see if they were
relevant data to suggest how the psyllid
is responding to the presence of the
bacterial pathogen and we did see some
responses that were consistent with a
with perception of seal acid pathogen
and before I showed this data I just
want to say this is counter to some of
the findings from Michelle's previous
work where say if it's transmitting
plant viruses do not show these sorts of
antiviral responses so the proteins that
I really want to draw your attention to
first there are several cubicle protein
Doozer involved in mechanical defense
they have been implicated in response to
bacterial and a number of different
insects there's several of these that
are upregulated in insects that are
harboring the seal a pathogen also there
were iron binding proteins that were
up-regulated this was interesting to us
because it's been established in many
systems including systems that some
people in this room work on that the
sequester and iron away from Oakland
pathogen is a strategy that a plant or
in this cave perhaps a vector and it's a
vector may be applying in order to
decrease the ability of the pathogen to
successfully do its pathogenic job
Esther aces these have been primarily
associated with increased or psycho
cellular systems we see a big spike in
in these esta races in infected sylhet
vectors and in addition to the
insecticide resistance though these have
also been implicated response to
bacterial pathogen
insects systems I just want to take a
minute to just kind of illustrate the
fact that that not everything is all
that cutting drive with this data
interpretation so there's a protein
cactus and some of you might be familiar
with which is a very well characterized
particularly in verse awful of fridge
role in inhibition and a Kappa beta
signaling in the toll signaling pathway
and here we have a relatively complex
relationship and I'll just walk you
through some of this data so this is the
the spectral counting data this is
averaged over three x replicates and we
see here that in the sea last infected
insects there's a big spike in these
inhibitors of NF Kappa beta sigma and so
this would be suggesting an immune
system suppression in the presence of
Libra vector but we have the opposite
scenario in the in the purple gradient
so here we have a big reduction in these
inhibitors of NF Kappa theta signaling
when the insects are affected in these
microbial fractions with microbial cells
and associated vector cells so we don't
really have a great explanation for that
except that this is a complex situation
the ACP or mean response seems based on
the whole acct data to being potentially
suppressed by the presence of the
pathogen this could be due to some
bacterial effector protein which is
suppressing the insect immune system but
we see the opposite response in the per
mole fraction so this is really
something that we need to do more work
to achieve some clarity now okay I'm
going to just delve into some metabolism
here and I'm just going to kind of try
to focus everyone's attention on the
central molecule here acetyl co a and
basically the bottom line here is that
we see a concerted upregulation of
citric acid cycle proteins in insects
that are infected with the the green
pathogen and this is really striking in
this acetyl co a as this point where the
flux can either go through acetyl co a
carboxylase into Melanie
is a precursor for fatty acid
biosynthesis alternatively acetyl co a
can be the substrate of citrate synthase
and the production of citrate feeds into
the citric acid cycle so it seems on
there's kind of a concerted metabolic
change in the insect upon infection of a
decrease in fatty acid biosynthesis an
increase in the citric acid cycle and
related to that we do see that there's
also enzymes in fatty acid degradation
upregulated in your doctor infected ACP
please include this he hydrogenase this
coenzyme a transfer Asia and the
stylings so again at this point we can
speculate on what the effect of this is
but at the bottom line we believe that
this supports the hypothesis that
there's a metabolic manipulation of the
vector by the insect or of the vector by
the pathogen which the pathogen may be
applying to increase the probability of
this transmission but right now we
simply see these changes in primary
metabolism more work is done to
establish what the actual effect is and
whether it does
yeah another metabolic pathway that i'm
going to introduce Natalie come back to
a little bit later and this is this
involves the degradation of Bailey so I
didn't know very much about bailing
catabolism so I'm I don't know if you
guys do if you're doing no more than I
did when I started but essentially
valine one of the core metabolic fates
of a link tab ilysm in insects is the
production of protein al quwain which is
really a central molecule in primary
metabolism and one of the main face in
the insect of protein Yoko leg is
juvenile hormone is produced from this
molecule in juvenile hormone is a very
important insect hormone if it has a
number of different functions is a
number of different juvenile hormones
and in the psyllid there there's an
unusual aspect of this metabolism which
is uncommon in insects and that is the
presence of propene yoko a carboxylase
protein now I want to say that I bring
missed your attention because this is
one of the proteins that we saw we knew
about this from the genome sequencing
but we see this protein upregulated upon
inspection and the substrate or that the
product of this is this s methylmalonic
aware and again we're going to come back
to that this a little bit later but in
addition to the upregulation of this
propio kawaii box lace there's a
concerted effort ulation of baleen
degradation so these three other
proteins in this pathway are also
significantly upregulated in infected
insects but with this enzyme Ethel
Melanie semi aldehyde dehydrogenase
again the situation is not entirely
straightforward between the two
different samples the whole insect and
the purple gradient samples so and the
whole insect samples there's really not
a big difference in the protein
is between a healthy and the expected
but there is a huge increase in this
protein in the purple gradient fractions
where there's much more of this enzyme
in the in the fraction associated with
the microbes keep this in line because
we're going to come back to this in a
couple slides because I'm going to just
take a related segue to say that another
class of proteins that we were very
interested to see upregulated in
response to liver factor were proteins
of the ACP bacteriocin violence i'm just
going to introduce you to these anions
and and tell you a little bit about what
we know about what's going on inside
DHCP so first of all lavake a-- this is
not always clear that it's a symbiotic
some systems and more resembles a
parasite i guess the most important
thing for you guys to know as may
already know it's been used in the
dengue virus mosquito system in an
effort to reduce transmission this is
seen as potential acpi of control agent
ba ba kia is spread throughout the
insect but these next two endosymbionts
are restricted in their in their
presence to the bacterial this is a
schematic of the bacterium here this is
a interspecies organ inside the aphid
that the special earth inside the
cylinder it's a specialized association
of insect in microbial cells and you can
see down here this this is without
staining just the yellow coloration of
the bacterial in an insect arena
selenium and this is the cross section
of the bacterium stained with
fluorescent probes to reveal that in on
the perimeter ourselves of Carson Ella
and in the interior ourselves a Croft
talent now to introduce you first to
Carson Ella one of the striking elements
that Carson Elias it's how small its
genome is
the smallest microbes yet discovered
0.17 megabass genome it's got a highly
reduced genome but it does have a number
of complete amino acid biosynthetic
pathways leading to speculation that the
carson allah is a nutritional cenveo
involved with provisioning facilit with
with amino acids lacking firms diet now
profit ella is a bit different this is a
bacterium that was just discovered in
2013 it's a bacterium that's unique to
the Asian citrus psyllid and there's
also ubiquitous among all populations of
the Asian citrus psyllid yet tested and
I guess I just want to draw your
attention to just a slight well the prof
dela these cells are in this sensational
cytoplasm in the middle of a bacterial
Matt and I really just want you two to
reinforce is the physical proximity
between this white matter which is the
the cytoplasm of this athan sorry I used
to study Athens of this sylhet adherence
to of this psyllid sell the proximity
between patella and and the cytoplasm so
genome analysis of cough della led to
the prediction that it is apology types
and synthesis specialists approximately
thirteen percent of its genes appeared
to be involved from Holly kitay
biosynthesis so naka machi and
reconstituted group the discover profit
Ella they D hplc mass spec analysis of
methanol extracts from psyllids and they
discovered a novel polyketide present at
high abundance in in the silicon and
poly key tides I expect many of you are
familiar with poly key times but just to
give you a bit
section they are found in many systems
in nature and I'm airily they're
produced by bacterial ingested by aunty
Doreen sponges or in some cases of
insects and there are many antibiotics
which are poly q times well naka machi
and true cos you discovered this
polyketide and they established that it
was a highly bioactive compounds using
cell viability assays with both rat and
human souls over not microbial cells so
so this is very interesting we have
certainly been where this paper and we
were keen to see that there was a
coordinated upregulation of profit ella
polyketide synthase polyketide synthase
proteins in our libra vector inspected
psyllids compared to the healthy
controls so there was really a you know
an immediate question that came to my
mind when I saw this data which is are
there more Holly Tetons activists in the
inspected personality sillas that was a
prediction based on this proteomic data
but we what we wanted to do the analysis
of the polyketides to see if we can
confirm that hypothesis and so to do
that we went upstairs to the fourth
floor BTW i for french Schroeder's loud
french schroeder is a world leader in
analysis of secondary metabolites from
basically any organism you could throw
at him and so Frank Schroder and his
graduate student Jason hookey worked
with us to quantify quantitate Polly
keep eyes in healthy and Weber matter
inspected a CT and I know this
chromatogram is difficult to see but
just just to introduce the data this is
an HPLC chromatogram or a methanol
extract of either healthy or infected
and these are two different infected
colonies with different progenitor
insects the the methanol extract is
fractionated according to its chemical
properties and there are two peaks
I want to draw your attention to the
first peak is diaspora and we
established this using mass spec
analysis and we saw the same of the same
power and I on a 484 mass-to-charge
ratio for that peak but this second
polyketide based on the analysis with a
short lab did that for sergeant the
second p based on the analysis of a new
rule out if this seems to be another
uncharacterized polyketide and this bar
graph on the mic just shows the
distribution and there's no error bar
because that I'm just presenting the
data from this one replicate we do have
a second replicate will be repeated that
I wasn't able to incorporate that into
this data but we do see that between the
healthy and the two inspected colonies
there is a significant up-regulation in
both of these polyketides in a
particular the second infected colony it
seems like you know these two peaks some
together are approximately the same but
there's a different distribution of the
two polyketides and and and the mass the
fragmentation patterns of these compound
really do reveal that they're probably
quite similar we're doing NM are
currently two to establish the
structures of these on that to confirm
the structured I African established
structure the second so our next
question from there really was okay so
I've tell is making more poly key types
in the effective insects now is that
because there's more telling the
infected insects or is there some
activation of polyketide synthesis and
prop tell if it's occurring upon
perception of liver vector and so we use
qpcr for quantitation of microbial copy
number we use standard curves to to
really unknown standard so we can
absolutely quantify the pathogen tighter
and what this data shows is that in fact
the sea lice infected sylhet do have
more profit I'll
this and violence and so the green bars
are the liver back to tiger and so you
know this i'm not going to go into but
for our purposes it's really a very
compelling piece of data that the
infection status is so much different
between these two colonies but also we
can see that between the healthy and
each of these infected colonies there
there is an increase in the number of
prof tell ourselves that we see okay I'm
just going to try to use this slide to
pull together what we know about or what
we what we are hypothesizing right now
about metabolic interplay among the ACP
vector and the seal a pathogen and
patella related to poly kita tableau so
so we see polyketide biosynthesis is
increasing upon infection reliever
Factor s methyl Melanie ocoee is most
likely the polyketide building block
that is making the cocktail apology
denied and our proposal is that this
regulation of bailing catabolism in
inspected insects is producing this s
methyl Melanie oak away as a poly cute i
building block which the psyllid is then
provisioning to rough dela for the
polyketide biosynthesis so one other
point to make all of these are our
mitochondrial enzymes and the bacterium
is just loaded with mitochondria so I
you know I just really present this as
the fact that not only does this model
come out of our data but based on the
physical properties of the distribution
of the bacteria the organism we feel
like this is this is somewhat believable
another component of this i mentioned
juvenile form of biosynthesis was where
protein oko a typically flux of that
goes through juvenile hormone induces
expression of katella jet and
and we see several vitellogenin proteins
that are downregulated upon inspection
so really right now we'd like to
directly test juvenile hormone levels
and see if these are actually modulating
in response to infection and this enzyme
is when we will be thinking that targets
that we'd like to use for silencing this
is one that we're very attracted to
first of all it's not in bumble bees
it's not in other insects that you're
going to find in a citrus grove so the
bio orthogonal effects on other insects
is reduced and it may be it may play a
critical role in disrupting the
production of poly key type i profit
ella and you know we don't know what
those polyketide do yet but that's some
of the work that we'd like to do so some
of this data we believe shows that the
infected insects have a metabolic
disorder that could be the result of
manipulation by the vector the psyllid
Navy sensing labrum after as a pathogen
of the insect not just a plant pathogen
is drastic metabolism changes in the
cylinder upon inspection and infection
libram actor affects the propeller
sym-bionic and there's a model that
we're developing a potentially a
bacterial tug of war between the semi on
and liver dr. Furr resources of the ACP
there's more diaphragm produced upon
infection with us we like to know why
and what that's in use for we discovered
this this mean pollock some type that I
showed you and identified enzymes and
baling metabolism in our potential
targets for not
to effect some measure of hcp controller
so I'm going to spend a few minutes here
as I wrap up my [ __ ] care another
project that is ongoing using tools of
our collaborator at University of
Washington jim bruce to to discover
protein interactions in this vector
pathogens anion pathol system again I'm
just going to revisit the concept of
circular transmission of Libra factor in
the ACP vector the pathogen must
circulate through the insight for
successful transmission crossing
multiple barriers to transmission we
want to identify novel targets for hlb
control and we have an experimental
approach that will allow us to discover
protein interactions relevant to
transmission of liberal actor and model
the shape of the interface giving us the
tools to design inhibitors of proteins
of the pathogen vector semi on that are
involved in transmission of the citrus
cream pathogen so the real the real tool
here protein interaction reporter
technology as i said was developed by by
Jim crews university washington these
are a couple of the critical references
that can go into great detail about
their technology i'm not going to go
into a lot of detail on this right now
because i don't have time but the
fundamental output or objective of this
work is to to map very precisely protein
interactions in cells and basically this
figure demonstrates that the cross
linker is penetrating selves and
cellular organelles the cross-linker has
a biotin tagline
with the staining is for here these
reactive groups react to surface exposed
lacings on protein surfaces and there
are about 30 angstroms apart so when we
identify proteins that are cross-linked
we have a distant constraint that can
allow us to do homology modeling of the
shape of this interface and there's a
number of different outcomes of this
cross-linking when the cross linker is
mixed with your cells of interest there
can be dead end cross links that can be
in intramolecular cross links to give
information on the protein
three-dimensional structure we're mostly
interested in the intermolecular
cross-links that give us physical
evidence of protein interactions so we
wanted to use create an enriched sample
as sorry material to increase our
chances of not just finding psyllid
psyllid protein interactions so I
mentioned previously that we use the
protocol gradient for enrichment I just
give you a slug more introduction to
this right now we basically homogenized
infected psyllids load the psyllids onto
this purple gradient and ultra suit
centrifugation leaves us with these two
grading fraction future in which not
just deliver back yourself but also for
the suddenness of ions and for the
Associated psyllid cells and these
you've done backlight live exchanged
show these are intact and viable
microbial cells that can be recovered
from grady so quite simply I mean not
simply but practically simply in doing
the experiment we add the cross-linker
to these in rich cells and proceed with
the protein interaction analysis
workflow and i'm just going to really
almost you know skim over this just to
say that the there's a sample
preparation step i described the
cross-linking reaction happens
temperature within an hour two proteins
are extracted adjusted and Grich mass
spectrometry ultimately gives us a
unique signature of the cross-linked
peptides bioinformatics has been used
identify the proteins that the peptides
come from and 3d homology modeling is
used to map the interface of these
proteins and in spite of the enrichment
still the vast majority of across rooms
that we saw were between two sylhet
proteins well we mind our data and we
saw three cross links that I'm going to
breach the [ __ ] for you today that
we're excited about following up with
and the first to relate to cross links
between Scylla proteins and innocent my
own proteins and these are ribbon
diagrams showing the cost of protein for
the cross-links residues indicated in
red and the first cross-linked you
between myosin of the psyllid this is a
molecular motor associated with the
cytoskeleton and infernal 8 synthase of
Carson Ella anthranilic synthase is
interesting because this is the
rate-limiting enzyme and biosynthesis
the Carson Ella associated with the ACP
has complete tryptophan biosynthetic
pathway all the other carts mella
genomes that our sequence i think
there's six more do not so this really
could indicate that there's a
specialized interaction between the
psyllid and carson le related to trip
and bias of the system and this could be
critical for the nutritional symbiosis
the second cross link that we found with
between another- and protein of the
psyllid and an anchoring
domain-containing protein of wolbachia
and there's some work and make you look
tough on you that characterize the
macchia genome is having a large number
of genes encoding proteins with
anchoring like repeats these include
potential effector proteins that Maeby's
create from Milwaukee and anchoring
domains are known
protein-protein interactions and this
includes the anchoring domain of myosin
phosphatase and myosin is a
well-characterized interactions and fuel
cells so at the first level these data
give us the tools to understand
biochemical processes which underlie
interactions between host and symbiont
and they also put us in position to dot
design inhibitors of these specific
interactions which may have an impact on
transmission of the pathogen just my
final data slide here piece of data that
we're really excited about was the
discovery of an unambiguous and i'ma
libra vector bacteriophage protein that
we found a cross-linked in these in the
PIR analysis of the image purple
fraction a lot of you are probably
familiar with the lysogenic in the lytic
cycle of bacteriophages so I'm not going
to go into this right now except to say
as I said before the conversion to the
stage from the lysogenic to oolitic
state may be a viable control strategy
and so first of all just the fact that
we see a beige protein produced inside
the psyllid is it is news to this field
there it's not it has not been believed
that the phage protein production is
occurring inside the psyllid although we
cannot discount the possibility that the
phase protein was made of plant and
indus ility consumed it but really what
we're really excited about is we have
structural details of this homo diner
orientation which may provide insight
into the function of this protein and
give us tools to manipulate the phage to
to provide a tool for treatment
Provencher effective trees or vectors
that carry the libra pac apology so to
wrap up my talk what I've tried to
describe you first of all is that we've
discovered proteome changes in insect
insect with Harbor the super screening
pathogen that revealed changes and
metabolism both of the vector and attend
dosa my aunts secondly with the protein
interaction reporter work that I've just
shown we've discovered protein
interactions involving pathogen and
indocin by on proteins within the vector
which may be targets for specific ACP
control we've got a lot of ongoing work
to follow up this work and there are
other projects that I didn't have time
to mention today but we're really
interested in testing this hypothesis
conversion of so availing to prompt
el-medina foreign there's isotopically
labeled valine that's available
commercially from sigma that we have
feeding studies planned with we've
identified this novel calling key time
we have experiments or over the shorter
lab is is currently doing in a mark to
characterize the structure in this and
as I said we are excited about this cost
of bacteriophage protein and we have
experiments planned to follow this up
with functional structural analysis so
there's a lot of people who have been
involved in this work I guess I just
want to start with some of the people
whose work I didn't talk about this sgn
solanaceae genomics network at eti
including Lucas Muller Susan Strickland
knowing Fernandez have been tremendously
helpful with bioinformatics work but
we've done
we owe them a lot of thanks but I really
didn't talk about their work that much
today all the members of the ceiling lab
especially Jacqueline Mahoney she takes
care of all the citrus and the insects
and does a tremendous job during Moore's
at chemistry undergraduate he's doing
great work on this project and I'll take
any questions and time this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu